lucky should need me a curse word its
2017 I think [ __ ] you is perfect brother
I love what his family name
that's the name grandma called me I got
that name from fuzzy the [ __ ] aflame
came from a compadre in my Gucci gulab
now
he said waka flocka flame I'm like the
[ __ ] is waka flocka flame way I used to
fight it I'm not walking Waka Flocka
Flame my name is Walker I'm Rick Dale
Walker like I say you know something
[ __ ] that I'm walk a [ __ ] flame my
first tattoo was on my fingers I was 15
going on 16 they say it's squad my
friend named Martin he actually learned
it in juvenile can we use a paper clip
and some kind of gun he made and it's
like poking me like I like that because
of gutter I felt like that was more
Street his squad is like a whole bunch
of young people from our community we
needed God it's a lot of us didn't have
that so we looked at each other for and
lose the edge squad but I gotta be done
there's actually like I'm in [ __ ] a
song song on my hand - on the south side
so it's s o u is this why I come from
Ebonics like I was Stern on it right
after that that's when I met Gucci
that's when I got so I see boys and
auntie actually was like ice blue and
white so white and all that - who's got
infected so I just like expressed a call
out of it
now that it flames today again I'm ready
lit lagoon
I got relief right here that's my little
brother that passed away I want you to
see what I really love these four
tattoos it's a man looking out their
cells
it's a Judge hand with a gavel a human
being was on got the window with two
guns and a graveyard
what inspired that because these are
traces that I normally see when I was a
kid this is animal living but I thought
it was cool that some homies and joke
all right that's not it's not the way
and it's ten out of ten everybody every
every family and hook I said somebody
dead I'll cut that on my neck I was cut
though period I want to put my pain on
because I never used to talk to people
sides on foot [ __ ] that really bothered
me in the inside on my flesh so cut
though I'm around cut though
[ __ ] all my life so hey I got a
joint regime it's cut it we could this
month favorites as video I'm getting is
that sooner my life was great my first
hour rapping I have no control over my
life but the [ __ ] hit me so hard like I
went from one weekend from begging my
mother $300 gonna roll to coming back
home with 60,000 in my pocket so you
know what I did with that by Monday I
was down like 12 miles I blew that [ __ ]
buying a crib buying TVs and paying
everybody moment bills we're gonna
sharpen so my life is crazy though cuz I
thought all that I started on experiment
different drugs too much alcohol reality
kicked in like Lu you like a [ __ ] lab
rat you look at rich elaborate that's
why I got this tattoo man I got this
tattoo I got a form of a skeleton
because to me the last time you see a
spirit is coming out the skeletons and
literally less than six months I'll be
shot where I hit a bull and [ __ ] bounce
hit the bone it comes down I hit my rib
cracked my rib one bullet come out and
like two inches away from my spinal cord
why the [ __ ] boat got shot four times
in one Buddha so when I was recovering
I was evolving into the man I am today
dumb skulls right there's personally
that's the story now I'm taking two
degree put his fault
no I got the skulls I have a wolf I feel
like they let a wolf in
if the Joker always loved the Joker and
I always loved him clown
I always thought clown as [ __ ]
play so you want to be a clown I'm
attorney to the Joker it wasn't like
some own thinking I was just young we
kill homies that come up but we really
kill in our race god bless us all like
when I got in the real world and
deepening colors in combat it was like
hey got business account how's your
credit okay
it won't a house pile of marijuana
cannabis is everything it's deeper than
just grabbing a blunt rolling up it's
smoking like a Coughlin it is fighting
out Bob Marley telling my back looking
face to face with a skeleton that's well
smoke come from I'm not a Ted Turner
work on some hanging with Steve Aoki
[ __ ] I forgot would even call this
tattoo it's like Bigfoot with a six
beggary
it's Steve out the same day intensive oh
right no tats hell no I don't do it
well I regret I regret waka flocka flame
why would you get your name big as hell
stomach hurts bad
my grandmother mama hood said don't
touch your face how they did and I ain't
[ __ ] with my face I mean it hoped my
mother my groom I never had tattoo my
face ever I'm all body tensed from top
to bottom
just know as always two ways to look at
these tattoos you'll get judged so don't
complain about being in judged but on
the other note man do they say express
your [ __ ] self man no pain no glory
no glory no time
[Music]
you